It's Mark Wiens here, I'm in Delhi, India,
and I'm about to eat one of the coolest ice
cream, I think I've ever had in my entire
life.
Ok, so I ordered the mango version, and it's
actually a mango hollowed out, and then they
put cream and other spices and stuff in it,
and then freeze it all in the mango. And then
they seal it with clay at the top, seal it
up, and then when you order it, it's hard
in the deep freeze, and they slice it up into
pieces.
So there's actually real mango on the outside
and on the inside is the ice cream, mango
ice cream, so, by far the coolest mango ice
cream I've ever eaten, kulfi, mango kulfi.
Awww, that's really cold, and really good.
Super creamy, really mango-ey, mmm, that's
fabulous.
Ohhh, that's very nice. Oh yah!